NARRATOR: Cusco, Peru.
Today, the Church
of Santo Domingo
sits on the foundation
stones of what
was once considered
the most important
temple to the ancient Inca--
the Coricancha
Temple of the Sun.
The original structure, which
is believed to predate the Incan
civilization, was rebuilt
in the 15th century
by the ruler Pachacuti after
he came into possession
of a mirror disc.
EDWIN BARNHART: Pachacuti is the
first Inca who really created
the Inca as an empire, not
just as one of many cultures
in the Andes.
ASHLEY COWIE: A legend
has it that Pachacuti
traveled to a spring
to the east of Cusco.
A disc was said to have fallen
from the sky into the spring,
and when Pachacuti lifted
it out of the water,
he saw an image of
Viracocha the Creator.
The apparition told Pachacuti,
You will win many wars.
Within 10 years,
Pachacuti expanded
the empire in a way that's never
been seen in history before.
The myths say that he
held that mirror with him
for the rest of his
life, and any answers
he wanted, to look into
the future or what to do,
he consulted the mirror, and
the mirror told him what to do.
ASHLEY COWIE: The disc
that Pachacuti found truly
was his key and his driving
force to become one of the most
powerful emperors in history.
NARRATOR: Pachacuti began
the expansion of the Incan
territory from the
Valley of Cusco
to encompass 2,500 miles of the
west coast of South America,
from Quito, Ecuador,
to Talca, Chile.
Worldwide-- it doesn't
matter what ancient culture--
there is some type of
a worship of a disc
that came from the sky.
It is possible
that this disc had
some type of an
extraterrestrial connection
and that this disc was
a technological device.
DAVID CHILDRESS:
You have to wonder,
was it some kind of an
extraterrestrial object
that Pachacuti was now carrying
around with him that allowed
him to communicate with these
extraterrestrial gods that
were guiding him?
DAVID WILCOCK: We've
already had smartphones that
have come out in our own
history where it's a lot
more than what it appears.
You're looking at
all of your apps,
you can watch movies on
it, you can send email,
you can have telephone
calls, you can have video
calls-- all kinds of things.
So that disc may have been
something with a great deal
of computer circuitry
in it, something
that had far more
capability than we
could ever normally imagine.
NARRATOR: If the accounts
of Pachacuti's magic disc
are true, could
it have contained
some sort of alien technology?
According to ancient
astronaut theorists,
further evidence that
alien discs exist on earth
can be found in the Hayu
Marca mountain region of Peru.
At the site known by the locals
as the Puerta de Hayu Marca,
or Gate of the
Gods, is an enormous
23-foot-high door-like
structure carved
into the solid rock face.
Contained within it is a
smaller, T-shaped opening
just under six feet in height,
with a circular depression
inside.
WILLIAM HENRY: Local legends
tell us that the gods would use
this as a gateway,
or a stargate,
through which they
would come and go.
They opened the doorway
through this disc
that was placed in a little
alcove, or etching place,
inside the doorway.
DAVID CHILDRESS: One
of the stories, too,
is that a high priest
named Amaru Meru utilized
a disc to open this door.
And so this was his
computer, or key, that opened
this dimensional doorway.
Once again, the
disc is the key.
Here we have an apparent
extraterrestrial technology
in the form of a disc.
And you would then pop the
disc into where the door is,
and that would open the portal.
This circular area
has been found
where the door is located.
And so it does suggest that
there may be some veracity
to these ancient legends.